rights for all that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now it wasn't until about 1992 when i
began my clerkship for justice clarence
thomas that i really began to pay
attention to how the media writes about
the supreme court
so i'm talking about the new york times
and the washington post time magazine
newsweek etc television reporters
90 of them believe that the court
rulings were radical and outside the
mainstream unless
those rulings affirmed whatever the new
york times and harvard law school
believed was the right outcome
understand
so from the death penalty to abortion to
criminal justice matters
liberal journalists and politicos
insisted that the supreme court act as a
rubber stamp for their views
so in cases where justices merely
applied the facts of the case to the law
oh forget it of course that's not the
proper understanding of the court's role
the court properly understood is a check
on both the legislative and the
executive branches and on the states
where constitutional issues are involved
so when the court today issued its 6-3
ruling striking down new york's
very restrictive concealed carry law the
reaction from the press and the assorted
democrats
it was textbook
the supreme court decision he's going to
call into question pretty much every
piece of
of gun restriction across the country
what the conservatives on the supreme
court are saying is we want the second
amendment to be a first-class right like
the first amendment and we want to be
able to carry guns anywhere anytime
without any sort of regulation by the
government problem here is so many
people get hit by these guns when you
read the news headlines every day of
children crossing the street people that
were doing nothing because everyone
decided to be a good guy with a gun of
course the idea that if you're in times
square amidst all of hubbub and human
reaction and potential gangs and so
forth and so on that people can be
easily carrying around concealed weapons
that's just startling we have a supreme
court that is out of touch with modern
day realities
david gergen
wrong wrong
oh and oh wait
wrong
okay justice thomas in writing the
majority opinion he interpreted the
second amendment
in the only way that makes sense
writing that the constitutional right to
bear arms in public for self-defense is
not a second-class right subject to an
entirely different body of rules than
the other bill of rights
uh guarantees we know of no other
constitutional right
that an individual may exercise only
after demonstrating to government
officers
some special need
well that's not how the first amendment
works it's not how the sixth amendment
works it's not how the second amendment
works when it comes to the public
carry for self-defense new york's proper
clause requirement cause requirement
violates the 14th amendment and that it
prevents law-abiding citizens with
ordinary self-defense needs from
exercising their right to keep and bear
arms
of course as usual my old boss is 100
correct
every other right in the bill of rights
is read to limit the government's power
to restrict it
the ten amendments were written by the
framers to protect us from a corrupt
oppressive government
of course the founders knew what it was
like to live under tyranny and therefore
the people's right to bear arms to them
was key to maintaining a free country
makes sense
of course left-wingers though in the
government across the united states
they despise the constitution
which means they're enraged over this
ruling
this decision isn't just reckless it's
reprehensible the insanity
of the gun culture that is now possessed
everyone all the way up to even to the
supreme court
and we cannot allow new york to become
the wild wild west will not allow our
city to live in fear
that everyone around us is armed
and that any altercation
evolve into a shootout
it's it's devastating i mean it's just
fundamentally devastating preparation of
illegal guns is a challenge of our time
and we have got to rise up as a
country yeah lightfoot because your
streets are so safe right
now every day these same people betray
the rule of law in their own cities and
states because
whether it's lori lightfoot or hulkel or
adams
they're content to leave their own
law-abiding citizens defenseless
and make the job of law enforcement at
the same time more difficult pretty much
at every turn
so for the regular person out there the
work a day person it's a lose-lose
proposition
but the elites
they always protect each other
celebrities and other special people
were the only ones new york believed had
the meaningful second amendment right to
carry a concealed weapon
now back in 2010 a list of new york city
concealed uh carry permit holders was
obtained by the new york daily news
people like mark anthony shock jock
howard stern robert de niro donald trump
his son donald jr mets third baseman
david wright and even martha stewart's
daughter radio host alexis stewart
all were authorized to carry a weapon
concealed in the city
now john schuyler chamber is a lawyer
who's helped a lot of new yorkers get
these gun permits for more than two two
decades now said that they can get their
own security but with the internet it's
much easier to find people they don't
want to find someone on their lawn at
five in the morning
okay
from just that comment we see the
absurdity in this new york law
democrats as usual cater to the elites
because they're the only ones who have a
legitimate concern about an intruder
showing up at their homes or threatening
them in public
well another reason you know the 63
court was right is by the silliness of
the descent
in it justice breyer of course who's
retiring rather than addressing the
plain language and the historical
circumstances that inform the words of
the second amendment
he discussed gun suicides and listed the
well-known mass shootings in america
like uvalde buffalo orlando
newton dayton and of course they talked
about all the horrors of that well alito
justice alito who is in the majority
wrote separately in a concurrence
he slapped back at justice breyer saying
you know why does the dissent think it's
relevant to recount the mass shootings
that have occurred in recent years
does the dissent think that laws like
new york's prevent or deter such
atrocities
will a person bent on carrying out a
mass shooting be stopped if he knows
that it is illegal to carry a handgun
outside the home
and how does the dissent account for the
fact that one of the mass shootings near
the top of its list took place in
buffalo
the new york law issue in this case
obviously did not stop that perpetrator
i don't know that's a heck of a
retirement send-off for breyer isn't it
now another obvious reason you know the
court got it right
reactions from some of the most
unhinged personalities out there
like former sports guy keith olbermann
who tweeted that the ruling shows that
the court should be dissolved
and advises that states just ignore the
ruling
now that's a neat trick
just ignore the court
remember these are the same people who
are constantly warning about how under
republicans democracy is at risk
democracy is in peril
i don't know
call me crazy i think that olbermann
should just stick to memorabilia
collecting because he's actually really
good at that
of course this is how it always works so
with these people when they don't get
their way
they want to tear down the entire system
in other words abolish the electoral
college burn city blocks tear down
statutes statues and pack the court
no forget packing the court just
dissolve it all together now that's
where we've come
this is sheer lunacy
it's anti-constitutional
it's anti-american
so in the end
this is not a radical decision it's not
a crazy decision
it's a long overdue decision
and contrary to all the cattlewalling
out there on the left the ruling doesn't
even mean that states have no power to
regulate guns
it just can't prohibit law-abiding
residents from carrying a gun for
self-defense
as justice alito noted
that's all we decide our holding decides
nothing about who may lawfully possess a
firearm or the requirements that must be
met to buy a gun nor does it decide
anything about the kinds of weapons that
people may possess
nor have we disturbed anything that we
said in heller or mcdonald versus
chicago about restrictions that may be
imposed on the possession
or carrying of guns
get it
but the modern american left they don't
they don't like you okay they despise
you you have to understand this and they
do not want the regular
ordinary people to be free to defend
themselves and their families
now why why don't they want that
because they want you dependent they
want you scared they want you groveling
for whatever scraps they decide to throw
at you
they'd abolish the second amendment in a
heartbeat if they could
and frankly the entire constitution for
that matter
but thankfully thankfully our founders
were very wise
they saw how power corrupted otherwise
sensible men and how important it was to
leave behind a document that would
protect all the people not just the
upper crust against the abuse and
thankfully
we have six justices on the court who
honored the plain language of the text
and the intent of the framers
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else